Okay.
I want to begin with a question today.
I have a question.
I have a question for you.
You've been reading the apology.
You've now read the,
you've read the apology and the Credo of had a little chance to think about
these,
uh,
works.
Uh,
I just liked to do a piece of survey research.
How many of you just show of hands?
Is,
is all I need?
How many of you believe uh,
Socrates is innocent and should be acquitted?
Okay.
And how many of you believe he is guilty and more or less got what he deserved?
Higher Place.
Okay.
Uh,
not exactly the same proportion.
I think somewhat a greater number of believe in his,
in his innocence then then in the Athenian jury,
obviously,
but let me just ask you,
you'll be in the,
in the brown shirt.
Just curious.
Why do you think he,
he is,
he is innocent and should be acquitted.
Well,
in terms of
the
politics
and,
uh,
you,
I noticed you had your yes.
Uh,
why did you,
why did you believe he was guilty and got what he deserved?
What is
what
society agrees?
I mean he was going against the people who had the authority.
What is justice,
what society says this?
It says what you did.
Okay.
So,
uh,
as Lincoln once said,
both,
both of you can't be right.
Uh,
neither of you may be right,
but,
but both of you can't be right.
So this,
this is a question that I want to continue today to come to consider,
uh,
what,
what the trial of Socrates means.
And I want to begin by going back to a problem or a paradox that I ended the
class with last time.
That is to say it's Socrates proposes a right,
a new conception of what it is to be a citizen.
He opposes,
we have seen traditional,
you might say,
Homeric conception of the citizen,
the citizen,
uh,
certain notions of citizen loyalty and patriotism,
created,
shaped by the poetic tradition going back to homer.
He wants to replace it with a new kind of,
uh,
want to call it rational citizenship,
philosophical citizenship,
uh,
a view of citizenship that a,
again,
relies on one's own powers of independent reason and judgment.
And in the course of debate and argument,
and in the course of defending this point of view,
Socrates says in a,
in an interesting passage that he has spent his entire life,
uh,
pursue.
Uh,
he,
he's,
he's spent his life,
uh,
pursuing private matters rather than public ones and is deliberately avoided a
public issues,
uh,
issues of politics.
And that raises a question,
how can a citizen,
how can this new kind of citizenship that he is proposing,
how can any kind of citizenship be devoted just to private matters and not
public?
Uh,
citizenship seems to require even,
uh,
the public sphere,
the public realm.
What,
what,
what does Socrates mean when he says his way of life as has been devoted almost
exclusively to private,
rented into public matters as well.
The first thing we might think about is whether that's entirely true,
whether he's being entirely candid with his audience after all,
uh,
the kind of investigations,
the kind of interrogations that he has been pursuing since going to the Delphic
Oracle,
and then then following,
it's his,
at least his interpretation of its mandate,
these investigations of the politicians,
the poets,
the craftsmen,
and the,
like,
he says he's had been carried out in public.
Uh,
he has gone around in a market and in the open,
in the Public Forum,
uh,
questioning and interrogating and obviously making a Var,
a variety of people look foolish.
So this is hardly simply,
uh,
a private question or a private way of life.
But perhaps he means simply that,
uh,
by pursuing a private life that again,
he's going to rely almost exclusively on his own,
uh,
individual powers of reason and judgment.
Not to defer or rely on such public goods as custom,
as authority,
as tradition,
uh,
things of this sort.
But I think Socrates means more than that,
more than simply he wishes to rely on the powers of private,
individual judgment.
Uh,
when he says that his way of life has been private,
he means that he has pursued a policy of,
of,
let's call it a principled abstinence from a public life.
Socrates is a great,
uh,
abstainer,
he has abstained from participation in the collective actions of the city.
Uh,
actions that he believes,
uh,
could only entail a complicity and active of public,
injustice.
His own motto,
uh,
if you wanted to do a scribe him a motto seems to be a variety of,
of the hippocratic oath.
You know,
their doctors famous have to do no harm,
uh,
and to do no harm.
He has a required of himself,
a kind of principle abstention from public life.
If George Bush described himself not long ago,
is that as the dis is the decider,
we might call Socrates the abstainer.
Well,
what does he mean by,
or what do I mean by a referring to his policies of abstention from political
life?
Uh,
do you remember?
He gives,
he gives a couple of examples of,
of what he,
uh,
of examples of this sword.
One,
one of them remember,
uh,
concerned his refusal,
to join in the judgment,
to condemn,
uh,
and execute the 10 Athenian generals,
who had failed to collect the corpses,
the bodies,
uh,
of the men lost in a particular battle during,
during the Peloponnesian war.
This was a mark of great,
great shame and disgrace.
Uh,
the generals were a actual event.
they were,
uh,
there was a kind of judgment of collective guilt and they were all,
executed there.
The leaders,
the generals of this particular battle.
And Socrates tells how he refused to,
uh,
engage in that kind of,
Jay to join,
to join the court,
uh,
in the judgment of their collective guilt,
a true,
true incident.
And the second story you remember from,
from your reading of the book was,
uh,
his telling,
reminding the jury how he refused to participate.
He was ordered by the 30 that the hated tyranny of the 30.
Uh,
he was ordered to,
uh,
assist in the arrest of a man known as Leon,
of Salah and an arrest that would have,
would have and did in fact,
uh,
lead,
to Leon's a execution.
And Socrates tells how he at considerable risk to himself refused to participate
in the,
uh,
in the arrest of this man in both,
in both of these cases,
uh,
I take it,
Socrates is point a is that his own individual moral integrity,
uh,
stands as a kind of litmus test you might say for whether to engage or disengage
from political life.
Uh,
I was the sort of man he tells the jewelry.
I was the sort of man who never conceded anything to anyone contrary to what is
just,
uh,
no doubt.
Also reminding them,
uh,
of his again is a refusal to bow to the,
to the tier two,
the two,
the 30 tyrants in the,
in the case of Leon of Sallome us.
But this raises,
I think that the central or a central point about Socratic citizenship or
Socrates is view of citizenship.
This kind of principled disobedience to the law.
Something,
uh,
like a thorough is a model of,
of,
of civil disobedience.
Does this,
uh,
does this policy of,
of,
of principal disobedience,
you might say vindicate or Indict Socrates of the charge of corruption in Po and
impiety that that has been brought against him.
Ken,
a citizen.
He,
he affirms,
uh,
I will ask though,
can a citizen put his own conscience,
uh,
above the law as Socrates seems to do?
This is a problem that we will see considerably later in the term in the term
that vexes uh,
a very important political thinker by the name of Hobbs,
uh,
about whether an individual can somehow put their own sense of conscience or
moral integrity.
Uh,
even above the law.
What would a community,
uh,
of Socratic citizens look like?
Each one,
uh,
picking and choosing,
you might say the laws or the rules to obey a,
or to follow or,
or,
or not to follow.
Socrates is so concerned it seems with his individual is private and moral
integrity that he says in a sense to the city of Athens,
to the court,
to the Athens,
to the assembly or the courts,
that he will not dirty his hands,
uh,
with public life.
And again,
this is a question that we will see later on that Machiavelli,
uh,
takes very seriously the question of whether or not politics,
political life requires one to dirty ones hands,
uh,
in the world.
What kind of citizen is it?
Is he or she who abstains from maybe even rejects a,
the harsh necessities,
requirements of,
of political life.
Socrates seems to be in star in some respects.
An example of what Hegel and in 19th century described as a beautiful soul.
You know,
someone who,
and he,
and he used that ironically I should say,
uh,
someone who puts their own private moral incorruptibility,
above all else.
Uh,
and we all know it probably know or have read about,
about people like this.
How does Socrates answered these charges?
He,
he have of in a way,
uh,
being not just an abstainer but,
but it can,
putting his own private moral conscience or integrity,
uh,
over and above the law.
And he tries to defend his point of view by arguing in a famous passage that his
policy of abstinence actually carries important benefits to the city.
He brings with it important benefits and an f in the passage that I'm referring
to,
he defines himself as a gadfly.
Everyone will remember that the gadfly who improves the quality of life in the
city in section 30 d a Socrates rights,
let me read the passage.
So I,
men of Athens are now too far from asking from making a defense speech on my own
behalf.
I do it rather he says on your behalf,
what I say,
I say for you,
he appears to say so that you do not do something wrong concerning the gift of
the God referring to himself,
the gift of the God by voting to condemn me,
for if you kill me,
he continues.
You will not only destroy,
you will not easily discover another of my sought who,
even if it is rather ridiculous to say.
So has simply been set upon the city by the God is though upon a great and born
horse who was rather sluggish because of his great size and needs to be awakened
by some gadfly just so in fact,
the God seems to me to have set me upon the city as some one of this sort.
I awakened and persuade and reproach each one of you and I do not stop settling
down everywhere upon you the whole day.
So here,
here we have the example of Socrates telling,
telling us not only declaring himself to be the gift of a God who is brought to
for this,
but that he is,
uh,
he's a great benefactor of the city.
That his pre,
his example,
his example of the,
of the man of,
of individual moral conscience brings with it great as it were,
public,
uh,
benefits.
It is not on his behalf.
He tells the audience,
but yours is fellow citizens that he,
he does what he,
he does.
You may not like me.
Uh,
he says to the jury,
but I am good for you.
And furthermore,
he claims,
uh,
in this,
what can only be described as sort of crazy religious language that he has no
choice in the matter.
This is not something he has chosen to do.
He is,
as he says,
a gift from the God he has been.
He argues to do this.
Men of Athens,
he says,
I will obey the god rather than you.
And as long as I breathe in and am able to do so,
I will certainly not stop philosophizing.
He seems to envelop him himself and his way of life with a kind of religious
imagery.
The Delphic Oracle,
uh,
the,
the gift of the God,
uh,
image.
He envelops his conception of citizenship within this religious language.
And this will,
will or should lead any reader of the apology in any reader of Plato to ask an
important question about Socrates use of this language.
We will see it again in different ways in the republic.
Is he sincere in saying this and making this point,
or is he,
or is he somehow being ironical,
uh,
in his use of the religious tone or the religious register?
He is after all on trial for his life,
for the charge of impiety.
Uh,
would it not seem that in order to rebut the charge of impiety,
uh,
that he would,
use or adopt a kind of religious language that would resonate with the jury and
rebut the accusation,
perhaps even suggesting that he is the truly,
uh,
religious and pious one and not the ones,
like annotations and Mellitus who are bringing charges against him,
Socrates seems,
or it could be seen to be speaking not just ironically,
but provocatively and describing himself as a gift of the God.
In a sense.
You might ask what could be more ludicrous,
uh,
Socrates declaring himself or anyone declaring themselves to be,
you know,
uh,
a gift of the divine,
but right.
I mean,
who,
who would make such a claim.
But in another respect,
he seems to take the divine calling very seriously.
Right?
I mean,
does he not?
Uh,
it was only when the Delphic oracle a replied to clarify on,
he tells that story that replied to him that no one was wiser than Socrates,
that Socrates undertook this second sailing as it were.
His turn.
We saw this last time has turned away from the investigation of purely natural
phenomena to the study of the world of moral virtue and justice.
He repeatedly maintains that the path he has taken,
uh,
is not of his own choosing,
but the result of a divine command.
He is under some kind of divine a edict,
and it is precisely his devotion to this divine command to this particular kind
of calling that has led him to neglect his worldly affairs.
Uh,
he reminds him at various points,
the audience of his extreme poverty,
um,
his neglect of his family and his obligations to his wife and children as well
as just suffer,
uh,
the disgrace and the abuse that is directed against him by various public
figures.
He tells,
he tells us all of this is the result of his devotion to the divine command.
He presents himself,
in other words,
as a human being of unparalleled piety and devotion,
who will risk life itself rather than quick.
The Post that has been given to him,
it's a very tall order that he,
he claims for himself.
Do we believe him in this respect?
I mean,
an important question.
Do we believe him?
Again,
is he being sincere in,
or is he using this as it were,
a kind of rhetoric,
uh,
with which to,
you know,
envelop his,
uh,
himself.
What is this peculiar kind of piety that he claims to practice?
Uh,
in many ways,
uh,
in replying to the jury's verdict,
and their request that he sees philosophizing,
uh,
Socrates explains himself in the following terms.
Let me just quote one other passage briefly from the second speech that he gives
to the jury after his,
his,
uh,
conviction.
It is hardest of all to persuade you
to persuade some of you about this.
He says,
uh,
about his way of life.
For if I say this is for,
if I say that this is to disobey the God and because of this,
it is impossible to keep quiet.
You will not be persuaded by me on the grounds that I am being ironic.
And on the other hand,
he says,
if I say that this even happens to be a very great good for a human being,
that is to make speeches every day about virtue and that the unexamined life is
not worth living for a human being,
you will still less be persuaded by me.
In other words,
what he,
he seems to be saying in that passage at around 37 c and D is that he realizes
he is on the horns of a dilemma.
On the one hand,
he says his reference to a divine mission,
uh,
he explicitly says there will be taken by his audience as being ironic.
Uh,
just another instance of Socratic irony and insincerity,
but he says,
if he tries to persuade people,
uh,
of the goodness and the justice of his way of life on simply rational grounds
alone to persuade them that the examined life alone is,
is,
is worth living,
he says he will not be believed.
So what you might say is a Socratic citizen to do.
Uh,
he will either be accused of being ironic and not be believed,
or he will simply be disbelieved if he,
if he attempts to defend himself on rational or philosophical grounds.
That raises the question.
I think that,
uh,
I began the class with today,
should Socrates be tolerated?
What a good society tolerate Socrates,
this is the question raised by dis dialogue.
And the Credo is,
well,
how far should freedom of speech and that is to say speech that verges in that
borders on or even verges into civic impiety.
How far should such speech be tolerated?
It's been an assumption of readers of Plato,
uh,
over the years,
that the trial of Socrates,
that the execution of Socrates,
uh,
presents,
the case for the fullest liberty or freedom of thought and discussion and the
evils or the dangers to a society,
uh,
of trying to persecute or,
or,
or suppress,
uh,
freedom of speech.
But,
but is this right or in other words,
is that really Plato's,
uh,
teaching among the things?
Uh,
Socrates says he cares deeply about his,
his calling as he puts it to do nothing but persuade you both younger and older,
not to care for your bodies and money,
but how your soul will be,
uh,
in the best possible condition.
Um,
kind of lost my place.
Oh,
yeah.
So,
uh,
let me,
sorry,
let me just get back to that.
Uh,
how are we to understand this case about toleration and freedom of speech?
The apology presents Socrates,
right as presenting the,
the most intransigent case for the philosopher is a radical critic or questioner
of society.
Socrates demands that the Athenians change,
not simply this or that aspect of their policy,
but he demands nothing less than a drastic,
I would even say revolutionary change.
Uh,
in Athenian civic life,
in Athenian Civic Culture,
he tells his fellow citizens right,
that their lives are not worth living.
Only the examined life is worth and you are not living examined lives.
Therefore,
your life cannot possibly have any value to it.
Even when presented with the option to cease philosophizing,
he refuses to do so on the ground that again,
he is acting under a command divine command and cannot do otherwise.
It's Plato asking us to regard Socrates is a man of high principal standing up
for what he believes in the face of death or as a kind of revolutionary agitator
who cannot and should not be tolerated by a society whose basic laws and values
he will not accept.
Uh,
to some degree,
uh,
I am inclined to answer those,
answer that both,
that both of those questions have something to them.
Maybe the answer or an answer to this question is revealed in the Credo,
the companion dialogue,
the companion speech that goes along with
lead apology,
although it typically gets much less attention than the apology in part because
I think the dialogue presents a,
as it were,
uh,
the city's case,
the case of the city against Socrates.
I mean,
consider some of the following.
If the apology presents the philosophers case against the city Socrates case
against the city,
the cryto presents the city's case against the philosopher.
Here's Socrates makes the case against himself.
You might say he makes the case against himself better than his accusers in the
courtroom.
Uh,
did so in the apology to speech between Socrates and the laws,
uh,
that forms a,
as it were,
uh,
the kind of central action of the dialogue presents the case that Mellitus and
annotate as should have made against him.
Why?
The apology seems to denigrate the political life as requiring complicity in
injustice.
And Socrates says he will have no part of laws or policies that entail
The cryto makes the case for the dignity of the laws,
the dignity or majesty of the city,
uh,
and its laws where the apology defends,
again,
a Po politics of principled abstinence or disobedience to the political life.
The cryto makes the most complete and far reaching case for obligation in
obedience to the law that has perhaps ever been made.
So how do we reconcile,
if we can these two apparently contradictory points of view in the,
in these two,
in these two dialogues,
these two dialogues,
it should be evident,
I mean,
differ not only in content but in their dramatic context.
Okay.
Just consider again,
some of the following.
The apology is a speech given before a large and largely anonymous audience of
over 500 persons.
The assembly that the court,
uh,
we see Socrates addressing,
the only time in any platonic dialogue in audience of this size.
The Credo on the other hand is a conversation between Socrates and a single
individual.
Only one person.
The apology takes place in the court of Athens.
The most public of,
of settings or the credo occurs within the darkness and confinement.
Uh,
of a,
of a prison cell.
Okay.
The apology shows Socrates defending himself and his life as a gift of the God
that most truly benefits the city.
But in the Credo we see him bow down to the authority of the laws that he seems
to have previously rejected.
And finally,
if the apology presents,
Socrates is the first martyr for philosophy,
the first person to die for the cause of philosophy.
The cryto shows Socrates trial and sentence as a case of justice delivered.
Okay.
These huge contrasts again,
they force us to ask a question.
What is Plato doing in presenting these two very different point of views,
points of view.
What does this point in presenting these two works with two such sharply
contrasting perspectives on the relation of Socrates,
uh,
to the city.
Okay.
What's Plato confused?
Was He contradicting himself?
Was He,
what?
What was he doing
requesting?
I hope I have time to answer it.
So let's look into the cried out just a little bit.
Credo is named for a friend and disciple of Socrates who at the outset of the
dialogue is sitting,
is a watchful guardian over his mentor urges Socrates to allow him to help him
escape.
The jailers have been bribed and escape would be made easy,
but rather than trying to convince cryto directly,
Socrates creates a dialogue.
Actually you might say a dialogue within the larger dialogue,
a dialogue between himself and the laws of Athens where he puts forward the case
against escape.
That is to say the case against disobedience to the law and the argument could
be summarized as follows.
No state can exist without rules.
The first rule of any state is the is the rule that citizens are not free to set
aside the rules to choose among them which ones to obey and to disobey.
To engage in dis in civil disobedience of any kind is not only to call this or
that rule into question,
but it is to call into question the very nature of law.
The very question of the rules to question or just obey the law is tantamount to
destroying the authority of the law.
The breaking of so much of a single law constitutes the essence of anarchy,
constitutes the essence of lawlessness.
It has a far reaching argument for obedience to the law.
The breaking of even a single law calls into question the authority of law as
such.
It's a very powerful argument that in a way Socrates makes against himself
putting that speech in the,
in the mouth of the laws.
But he goes even further than this.
Uh,
the citizen he says,
owes his very existence,
took the laws.
We are what we are because of the power and authority of the laws,
the customs,
the traditions,
the culture that has shaped us.
The laws he says have begat us.
Uh,
and the use of that term begat in our translation is clearly intended to
resonate with something you might say we might,
we might think of as something biblical about it.
Uh,
the citizen is,
is it in a word created begat a by the laws themselves.
They exercise a kind of paternal authority over us,
uh,
such that a disobedience to any law constitutes,
an active impiety or disrespect of the oldest things,
uh,
around us.
The laws are not only like our parents,
they are like our ancestors.
The founding fathers is,
we might say,
who are owed respect,
uh,
and piety in many ways.
The cryto in some respect is the platonic dialogue about piety.
Uh,
Socrates seems to accept here entirely the authority of the law.
He does not offer arguments for noncompliance as he does in the,
uh,
apology.
So what happened to what happened all of a sudden to Socrates,
the apostle of civil disobedience,
Socrates,
the apostle of principled abstention,
he accepts entirely,
or the laws forced him to accept entirely the covenant that every citizen has
with the laws that binds them to absolute awe.
Obedience.
The question is why does Socrates,
uh,
exhibits such proud defiance and independence of the laws in the apology in such
total,
uh,
even kind of a mouse,
like a rawhide acquiescence to the laws in the,
in,
in the cryto what happened to him?
I mean,
why is he a,
all of a sudden,
uh,
become so humble and acquiesce and
what happened to his language about being the gift of the God?
Okay.
Well that's,
that's something I want you to think about and maybe I'm sure you,
you want her to talk about in,
in your,
in your sections,
but let me propose something like the following,
uh,
to answer or at least to respond to this,
this paradox,
this question,
the apology and the cryto represent a attention.
They represent even a conflict between two more or less permanent and
irreconcilable moral codes.
Okay.
The one represented by Socrates,
regardless of reason,
that is to say the sovereign reason of the individual as the highest possible
authority.
It is the philosophers reliance on his own reason that frees him from that
dangerous authority of the State and safeguards the individual from complicity
in the injustice and evils that seem to be unnecessary.
Part of political life here is Socrates,
the,
the principal abstainer.
But the other moral code is represented by the speech of the laws,
where it is the laws of the community.
It's oldest and deepest beliefs and institutions.
It's its constitution.
It's regime as we would say.
It's Polo Taya that are fundamentally obligatory on the individual and even take
priority,
uh,
over the individual.
The one point of view takes the philosophic life,
the examined life to be the one most worth living the other takes the political
life,
the life of the citizen engaged in the business of deliberating,
legislating,
making war.
And peace is the highest calling for a human being.
These constitute to uh,
irreconcilable alternatives to different callings,
uh,
so to speak in any attempt I think to reconcile or to synthesize these two can
only lead to a deep injustice to each playdough seems to believe that each of us
must choose somehow must choose between one or the other of these two contenders
for the most serious and worthwhile way of life,
which do we take weight,
which is the matter of ultimate concern or care for us,
which,
but we cannot have both.
And I think that distinction to some degree captures the differences set out.
When I asked what the beginning of the class about who,
uh,
believes Socrates is innocent and should be acquitted and who believes he is
guilty and should be condemned between a philosophical and a political point of
view.
And in a sense,
one could say maybe this is not Plato's last word.
Uh,
I mean,
why does Socrates choose to stay and drink the hemlock?
Uh,
after all,
if he has committed a fundamentally to,
uh,
the principles of his own reason,
still,
why should he care that much about the laws of the city?
Why not let a credo help him escape and go to Crete,
uh,
where he can drink the good wine of Crete and enjoy his old age.
And in fact,
Plato wrote another dialogue,
his largest dialogue,
a book called the laws where you see an a,
a man simply designated as the Athenian Stranger living in Crete and carrying on
a conversation with representatives of,
of,
of that society.
And that might be Socrates,
that that might be,
uh,
although sat he is not identified as Socrates.
It is sometimes thought here,
here is the kind of speech or discussion Socrates would be having had.
He escaped.
But let gets back to the question.
Are there reasons Socrates gives cryto for refusing to escape?
The reasons he puts in the mouth of the laws of the city of Athens.
Are those Socrates is true reasons,
just Socrates believe that speech that he constructs between himself and the
laws,
or is it simply a fiction that he creates for the sake of relieving his friend,
uh,
of the guilt he evidently feels for being unable to help.
Socrates cryto is of course,
very concerned with what people will think of him.
Uh,
if it becomes known that,
uh,
he has somehow not a helped Socrates to escape.
Uh,
is that speech for the law,
a law with the laws really intended for the benefit of Cryto,
uh,
rather than an expression of Socrates is deepest,
opinions about the questions of obligation in obedience.
Is he in that speech bestowing as it were,
a kind of justice,
uh,
to Cryto,
to reconcile him,
uh,
to the laws of the city and to give him reasons,
you might say rational considerations for a ob continued obedience to the law.
In many ways,
that would seem to make a certain sense of the apparent discrepancy between
these two dialogues.
It demonstrates,
uh,
not only Socrates's sense of his superiority to the laws of Athens,
for in the first dialogue,
he and the first speech and the apology,
he defies,
uh,
the city to put him to death,
by expressing indifference to death.
And then in the cryto,
he very much,
uh,
expresses that indifference to death by refusing to allow Criteo to let him
escape.
Socrates seems to remain even until the end,
very much a kind of law unto himself a while.
At the same time,
again,
providing cryto,
uh,
and others like him,
an example of rational and dignified,
uh,
obedience to the law.
When we look at the death of Socrates,
do we think of it as a tragedy?
A is a moral tragedy
and adjust man,
uh,
sentenced to death by an unjust law.
I don't think so
far from it.
Socrates death at the age of 70,
was intended by him,
uh,
as an act of philosophical martyrdom that would allow future philosophy to be
favorably recognized as a source of courage and justice.
In one of his later letters,
Plato refers to his attorney.
He refers to his depiction of Socrates as he says,
his attempt to render Socrates young and beautiful.
That is you consciously set out to beautify Socrates,
presenting a man,
a fearless before death,
uh,
refusing to participate in any act of injustice while dispensing wisdom and
justice to those who will listen.
We don't know the real Socrates.
All we know of Socrates is a,
what we read in Plato and Aristotle Monies.
Uh,
and,
and a small number of others who have sketched various different pictures of
him,
but Plato,
Socrates,
a is necessarily poles apart from aristophanes's Socrates depiction of him as a
sort of sofas who makes the weaker argument is stronger.
Plato's dialogues,
the apology and as well as the republic and the credo are in the broadest sense
of the term and attempt not only to answer the charge against Aristophanes,
but also defend the cause of philosophy.
Yeah.
Uh,
as something of,
of value and merit,
where does that leave us today?
What are we to make of all this?
We who live in a very different kind of world from that have,
you know,
fourth century gethin's.
What can we learn from the example of Socrates?
Most of us,
like most of you earlier,
find ourselves instinctively taking the side of Socrates against the city of
Athens.
Those who might defend the city of Athens against Socrates.
Those who believe in the value of civic piety,
uh,
are very few among us.
Perhaps only those of you who might come from a small town in the south or from
certain areas of Brooklyn a would understand something about,
uh,
the,
the supreme value of,
of piety.
Uh,
as a way of life.
we by and large tend to accept the picture of Socrates,
uh,
as a victim of,
of injustice.
We overlook,
we conveniently overlook a number of facts about him,
his hostility to democracy.
We'll see that in the republic,
but we've seen it already to some degree in the apology is claimed that the
lives of his fellow citizens are not worth living.
Uh,
and his claim that his way of life has been commanded by a god that no one else
has ever heard or seen.
None of these seem to make any difference to us and yet I think they should.
Yeah.
Given Socrates's claims,
ask yourself,
what would a responsible body of citizens have done?
How should they have acted?
One answer might be to extend greater toleration to civil dissidence like
Socrates,
a individuals of heterodox belief,
but whose own views may stimulate others to question and think for themselves
all to the good.
Milton John Locke.
People like Voltaire argued something like this,
but is that to do justice to Socrates?
The one thing that does not argue is that play is that Socrates should simply be
tolerated to tolerate his teaching would seem to trivialize it in some sense,
to render it harmless.
The Athenians at least pay Socrates the tribute of taking him seriously,
uh,
which is exactly why he is on trial.
The Athenians refuse to tolerate Socrates because they know he is not harmless.
That he poses a challenge,
a fundamental challenge to their way of life and all that they hold to be noble
and worthwhile.
Socrates is not harmless because of his own professed stability to attract
followers.
A few today,
a few more tomorrow,
who knows to tolerate Socrates would be to say to him that we care little for
our way of life and that we are willing to let you challenge it and impugn it
every day.
Is that good?
Is that right?
The trial of Socrates asks us to think about the limits of toleration.
What,
what views,
if any,
uh,
do we find simply intolerable,
is a healthy society a one that is literally open to every point of view?
Freedom of speech is naturally a cherished good.
Is it the supreme good?
Should it Trump all other goods or just toleration reach a point when it ceases
to be toleration and becomes in fact a kind of soft denialism that can extend
liberty to everything precisely because it takes nothing very seriously.
And by nihilism,
I mean the view that every preference,
however squalid base or sorted must be regarded as the legitimate equal of every
other.
Is this really tolerance or is it rather a form of moral decay that is simply
decided to abandon the search for truth and standards of judgment?
There's a danger.
I think that endless tolerance leads to intellectual pacivity and the kind of
uncritical acceptance of all points of view.
Well,
so much for that.
Uh,
what I want to do,
uh,
I see we're running out of time is if you could think about it,
maybe hope,
hold that thought in your mind once in a while between now and Wednesday and
then Wednesday we will begin,
uh,
reading,
what is arguably many people,
some people believe the most important book ever written,
Plato's republic.
See you on Wednesday.